today include the people that are over
the age of 30 40 50 and 60 and I don't
really think he takes into account how
much social media has influenced the
culture and women in particular so I've
said this before and I'll say it again I
believe that attention to women is the
same thing as sex to men you know and
how I came to this conclusion is if you
ask women if you could be beautiful the
rest of your life you could look 22 the
rest of your life but you would never
sleep with anyone again most women would
pick the beauty over getting to sleep
with someone um I don't know say Jason
mimoa or whoever it is right where men
on the other hand wouldn't pick the
looks they typically would pick sleeping
with the hot chicks which it it shows us
something that we intrinsically desire
women desire to be desired or men desire
to you know have a lot of a lot of hot
chicks you know what I mean